Good morning.
All right.
I want to spend a moment to
help reintroduce the mobile web.
At [? DN, ?] at Google
we love the web.
The web is in Google's DNA.
Google, as a company,
grew up with the internet
along with everyone else.
We want the web to be
first class because there's
a lot of intrinsic
values about the web
that we really care about.
The web offers a
frictionless experience.
You can just tap a
link and you're there.
Experiencing what
that link led to.
You don't have to
pause and think about,
make decisions, do you trust
it, do you want to install it?
You can just move into new
experiences effortlessly.
The web is also discoverable.
It's all just built
on top of URLs.
A single URL has a lot
of power because it
represents its content.
But I can do quite
a lot with it.
I can store it so that I can
revisit it again, of course,
but more powerful, of
course, is sharing.
Links are shared by
all sorts of means.
And with those links, a
single app or document
can link into the state or
another section of any other.
And that link is
just a single tap
away from absolutely everyone.
The web is everywhere.
Interoperability is
this beautiful thing
that's let the web
flourish because it's
a shared, open platform, with
multiple implementations.
That's the platform.
That platform is on every
device and that single link
can be accessed by everyone.
And yet, you might have heard
some less than favorable views
on the mobile web.
Not everyone is convinced.
But respectfully, we disagree.
Its had its rough times, and
we may have missed the boat
a few times, but I want to
share what we've done about it.
The mobile web is
very much alive.
The reality is today,
the web, is multi-device.
And the count of users accessing
it on devices is growing.
And more than just increasing
the number of users,
the web itself is turning
to be more mobile.
In just eight months,
the number of sites
that are mobile
optimized has risen
from 47 percent to 60, 68, even.
Things are improving fast.
But the question is, why isn't
this happening even faster?
Why aren't all sites
great on mobile?
And what's holding
back developers
from delivering fantastic
experiences on the web?
So, about a year
ago, developers were
asked what stops them
from building with HTML 5?
And cited were items
like performance, APIs,
difficulty in building rich
UIs, and immature frameworks.
And we heard three key pain
points come out of this.
Speed, integration, and polish.
At Chrome, we take these
challenges seriously
and we've been putting
a deep investment
into the mobile
web and investments
into addressing these
specific pain points.
So I want to share
an update of what
we've been doing in the past six
months to make the web better.
First thing that we can do is
just make the platform faster.
We want to improve the speed
of the most common interaction,
the tap.
For a long time there's been
this 300 millisecond delay
on all taps.
The browser is waiting for
a double tap to happen.
We [INAUDIBLE] remove
this delay entirely,
making a dramatic impact
on the input latency
that all users have.
Since then, Firefox and
Safari have done the same.
Now we focused on other
input latency actions
like, flinging the page,
and made good improvements
there as well.
The JavaScript engine
inside of Chrome, V8,
has long been a
leader in performance.
It's speed on mobile is a
large focus for the team.
And we're happy to report strong
gains in our execution speed,
reduction in GC latency,
and a lower memory
footprint on mobile devices.
It's our goal to get the
browser out of the way
so that you can have full
use of the main thread.
This is a look at the
same frame of animation.
The second one is
taken six months later.
We've been making
core improvements
to the rendering engine,
blink, inside of Chrome.
These improvements have spanned
across the entire architecture.
From the compositor, to style
engine, to layout, to paint.
You can see on there we've
moved to this particular frame
of information from
18 milliseconds down
to 10 milliseconds.
Now, 8 milliseconds difference
may not sound like a lot,
but we've made this improvement
so that all web content doesn't
animate at a steady animation,
but we can get 60 FPS.
On the whole, we've improved the
speed of animation 75 percent
and scrolling 35 percent.
All this faster than
what we had in 2013.
We're committed to helping you
get 60 FPS on the mobile web.
So speed was identified
as a pain point,
and we've delivered marked
improvements in Chrome
on mobile.
Now that we're making
experience faster,
we need to give you more
control over the platform.
So this means new
APIs and features.
One of the most fundamental
features is service worker.
You can think of it as a
successor to app cache,
and it is, but it's more
powerful than just that.
It allows you to build
offline first experiences.
Service worker can
manage resource,
fetching, and caching
on your behalf.
And for users, it's
a huge win too.
Because they can
get content faster
and they can finally
have proper offline
first experiences
delivered from the web.
Service worker also unlocks a
number of high value futures.
Push notifications
is a great example.
Time and again, we heard from.
You want proper push
notifications on the web.
So they're on the
way and they're
being powered by service worker.
Other capabilities like
background sync and geofencing
are also coming, sitting on
top of this powerful primitive.
The web platform has long
been monetized, right?
E-commerce kind of changed
the way that retailer is done.
But in the shift
to mobile, things
got a little bit more difficult.
Keywords vanished so input
is a bit more difficult.
Requestautocomplete
is a new standard.
Let's show quickly
what this looks like.
Ah, just kidding.
Requestautocomplete
allows you to build off
of the HTML5 standard
autocomplete attribute.
And you can dramatically
improve the process
of filling out a checkout
flow and other forms.
We've seen a great
improvement on mobile
where a user can come
through checkout flow
far faster than dealing
with their thumbs
on text fields all day.
Now WebGL, of
course, offers great,
hardware accelerated,
3D content on the web.
And I want to show this demo to
you because it's really nice.
If I come over here to my phone.
You can Google
this yourself, just
look up Samsung Racer WebGL.
I'm going to click into it.
And this experience, which
is built with WebGL and also
Web Audio.
So it loads up.
There we go.
And we have a nice 60
FPS experience of WebGL,
here on my phone, on the web.
And I pan around, too.
The panning is done
dynamically with Web Audi API
so I really get
into the experience.
And you can see, we're
not missing frames,
this is a full slick
60 frames per second.
All right.
So, while the browser
needs extra features
so that you can deliver
these great experiences,
we also want to help users
get closer to your content.
So you saw in yesterday's
keynote the redesign recents.
So your web tabs move and
merge along with recent apps.
This allows you to move
easily between context,
whether it is web or app.
So we heard you when said you
needed a more complete feature
set and we've been
delivering on that.
Now no matter how web apps
are built, appearances matter.
The web deserves to
look and feel gorgeous.
In yesterday's keynote,
you saw a material design.
A unified vision for visual
motion and interaction design
across different devices.
Polymer has an
implementation of the this
that you can use
no matter what sort
of device it is, laptop, tablet
or phone, whether you're user
is using a mouse,
track pad, or finger.
The web's got the
same great looks
and we're bringing a beauty
back to the web with material
design.
I'm going to come
over, we're going
to take a look at one of
the applications built
with this powerful
design promise.
So this is an app, the
quiz app, called Topeka.
Its built with Polymer.
So it's built with the
next generation of the web.
But beyond that we made sure
to deliver a great experience.
So I'm going to come down here.
And as we move around there's
a lot of things happening.
We have simultaneous animations
and slick 60 FPS animation.
I'll come back and we'll
go down to profile.
And as I tap in on
the input selection,
you can see a nice
effect coming off.
You can see a
similar effect, too,
when we come in to
science and nature.
And as I'm selecting--
Hm, what is
the only bird that
can fly backwards?
Albatross?
Pelican?
I'm not sure.
What is the answer?
Hummingbird, yes.
The nice thing here is
that we have a paper ripple
effect coming off from
the placement of where
I put my finger.
Yes!
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
All right.
One last stop over
in TV and movies.
Select the actors who
played James Bond.
I know this one, that's good.
Dalton?
Yes.
Niven?
All right, yeah, that's good.
Yeah, I think that's it, right?
But we have this nice check box
effective coming in on the web.
Aw.
All right.
Well that was great.
I'll come back to my slides.
Zero points, all right.
We're excited to have
strong UI components and UX
paradigms for you to
build experiences with.
Now we know that implementing
all the most awesomest
features in the
world doesn't matter
if the platform is
hard to write code for.
So we've been investing
in develop ergonomics
and tooling to make it
easier for you to build.
Polymer is a framework for
building the next generation
of web and it builds on the
power of web components.
Now we've been working
on this for a few years.
And the engineers
who work on Polymer
work in conjunction with those
that work on the web platform.
And this collaboration
has worked out really well
and has benefited everyone.
It's great because
the web platform
gets to benefit from these
great web developer centric use
cases.
And meanwhile, we can make
sure that the implementation
of Polymer can stand the
fast path of performance.
This here's a look
at Polymer designer.
This is a drag and drop
UI for constructing
fast prototypes
and other things.
Not only can I drag and up
all these components together,
but I can instantly dive
into the code beneath them.
Now we care a lot
about making sure
that the ergonomics of building
with Polymer is smooth.
Using web components
is just HTML.
So take this a
Google map element.
Once I important
it, I can use it
very naturally just
with attributes.
Meanwhile, the element
itself encapsulates and hides
its implementation so I
can just reuse it easily.
But as you're
developing you need
tools to give you strong
insight into the performance
of your app and a great
expectation of what it's
going to look like
your mobile users.
So we've been working
hard to bring you
a great mobile development
and debugging experience
with the Chrome Developer Tools.
Including rich device
simulation features,
powerful remote debugging,
and rich instrumentation
to understand how to
improve performance.
So whether you're
working with Shadow DOM,
ES6 promises, we
want to make sure
that the Chrome
DevTools are behind you
helping you could
iterate quickly.
And you can move fast, focus on
delivering a great experience,
rather than focusing
on the technology.
Beyond the DevTools,
there's two more sites
that are critical in helping
you deliver on the web.
PageSpeed Insights
will run your site
against a battery of tests.
Help you identify not only how
to improve your page load time,
but also UX concerns.
Like sizing your tap targets
to be appropriate size
and also improving text
readability on small screens.
This is web page test.
It recently added great
mobile device support.
So which is an invaluable
tool in helping
you optimize for
the critical path.
So take something as fuzzy
as slow page loading.
Web page test helps you zero on
in exactly what's holding you
back.
Here we're looking at
the film strip few.
The film strip view
is a great look
at correlating the
network waterfall,
along with the visual
load of the page,
so you can identify
what's blocking
and how to make things faster.
And so, there's a lot
going on in web development
and we know that keeping up with
all the best practices of web
development is a full time job.
So how do we address
responsive design, responsive
layout, images, navigation,
hamburger menus, rich input,
rich media.
At web fundamentals
we've documented
some of these answers
into living gods.
We're hopefully making the job
of building for the modern web
a little bit more sane.
And taking the right
first step is key.
So we've shipped web
starter kit just last week.
It is a boilerplate for
building multi-device sites.
It sets you on the right
path with smart defaults.
Some of the things
inside web starter kit,
it has a complete set of styles
and components and layouts.
It's style guide is
driven by components.
So you can help craft
your visual identity
with your designers.
And tooling for build process
and smart developer workflow
ergonomics, like device
synchronization and LiveReload.
So to recap, developers assets
for an even faster runtime,
even better ergonomics and
tools, and more beauty.
We've had our heads
down to make big strides
and we hope over
these two days of I/O
you've seen some of this.
But we can't do it without you.
The web is open, the
web is a conversation,
and it's a collaboration,
and we need your help too.
Actually, let me take
a moment and tell you
about a guy named Dominic.
Dominic is just like a
JavaScript developer,
just like you and me.
Dominic, a while ago,
was taking a look
at handling
asynchronous operations.
He ended up writing a blog post.
This blog posts he
was saying there's
a lot of people doing work
inside JavaScript libraries,
but he made the case for saying,
the way that we're handling
asynchronous events
should be standard.
We should be able to have all
these of libraries interop
with each other.
This blog post
begat a test suite.
The tests suite begat 30
compatible interoperable
implementations.
One of which ended
up in the Dom sped.
Soon enough, with
Dominic's help,
the promises has landed in
ECMAScript, the language.
So going from a blog post
to landing a major feature
that a number of web APIs
are built is a big feat.
And not everyone is Dominic.
I'm certainly not.
So what can we do?
First, we just want
to hear from you.
Anything that you
can tell us on why
it's difficult to build for
mobile, what we can do for you,
what features you
need, what's slow.
Let us know.
File bugs, be active
on mailing lists,
just give us the feedback so
that we can serve you well.
And this also goes
almost without saying,
but build responsibly.
It's our awesome
opportunity to build
these frictionless
experiences on the web
to all users
regardless, regardless
of what screen
they're looking at.
The number one thing you can
do to make your site better
for mobile users is
just to make it faster.
With DevTools, Polymer,
and the other resources
I shared, you have a
whole host of tools
not only to keep you on the
fast path of performance,
but help diagnose and address
when you fall off that.
And, for a lot of users,
their first experience
with your brand is
your mobile website.
So they'll tap on a link that
was shared with them maybe
via Facebook, or email
to them, and they got it
over IM, found on a
pin board, or maybe
they just tapped on
a search results.
But they arrive
via the mobile web.
Now once they're in,
they might eventually
find their way to a naively
installed app, and that's fine,
but they came through
the mobile web.
And it's your responsibility to
deliver success on that place.
So this morning
I shared with you
how we're making Chrome
faster from input latency
to JavaScript to
massive improvements
in the core rendering speed.
We've looked at
powerful capabilities
like Service Worker,
push notifications,
requestAutocomplete, and
integrated web and App Recents.
We're making the web
beautiful and enjoyable touch.
And we want to make sure that
it's also a joy to build.
So we've invested in Polymer,
the DevTools, and other tools
to keep you on the right path.
We've done a lot of work, but
we're just getting started.
Chrome is committed
to the mobile web.
Chrome and Google are
committed to improve the web
for developers and
for your users.
We're not done yet, but
you can get started today.
Join us.
Let's help deliver
on the promise
and the power of the mobile web.
Thanks.